Pete this is really annoying well what's
that well I'm on google.com slash
finance and this is ridiculous
I have to pinch and zoom like crazy and
look my fingers take up like half the
screen how am I supposed to hit a button
that's only ten pixels tall yeah and try
and look at that same site on your TV
it's just as bad oh come on people don't
actually do that to themselves do they
it's crazy they do the mobile market is
growing faster than any other market and
if you're a web developer and not
building for mobile devices you're just
gonna lose all of your users that's the
core concept behind responsive design
make your content work across any device